ladies and gentlemen um maybe you might
want to meet mr. Hugh Jackman you didn't
think I'd miss it not in all I tell you
guys doing here doing down the back oh
good
Hawaii Chris good to see him in Oh
hugging up I got to say up until about
two days ago I had no idea that footage
existed honestly I never knew someone
was filming at Tom DeSanto was filming
as someone dug it up I think Brian made
them find it and man have I aged oh crap
moving for three words for you guys oh
man Logan that's all I'm saying read
into it what you will listen it is 16
years since that day almost and I got to
tell you playing the legend that is
Wolverine is the greatest part I have
ever had in my life I'm biased I think
it's the greatest comic book character
ever made but ever and I have to tell
you I'm here today for one major reason
that is to thank all of you the fans
because you are the greatest fans any
actor could have a dream of having you
are the most loyal most passionate you
are definitely the most honest sometimes
brutally honest yes when we haven't
always got it right you've told us but
you've always been there and for that I
thank you from the bottom of my heart
and I also wanted to say thanks to the
worldwide team that is 20th Century Fox
led by the man who's been there from the
beginning Jim gianopolous this is
sounding like an abit tree I hate this
I'm sorry I mean look I know that killed
off Wolverine in the comic books
recently but hey in the movies he's not
dead yet what does that mean what is in
store well what is in store I want to
tell you so bad but as I promised this
next time is going to be my last time
our putting on the claws one last time
and there it is
haha there it is but honestly this has
been the greatest thing that ever
happened to me and I thank you guys but
I also right now I have to tell you that
in this movie that we're going to make G
it's going to be directed by Jim mangled
the great Jim mangled and yeah he's
awesome and we are we have so many great
and I can tell you that the people in
this room in particular the fans in this
room I think it's going to be the best
one yet for you guys that's what I
promise you
so I also want to thank before I leave
the stage I really want to thank one
person who helped me bring Wolverine to
life who also gave me my very first
United States film job the one and only
the amazing genius Bryan Singer coming
here Bryan
that is literally the first time I've
seen you run ever ever ever I don't run
are you okay I made it paramedic no that
was very emotional I had never seen that
before
I know it was gonna look you know that
look on my face when I was completely
shocked like I had no idea because I
have never known more in my life that I
had not got a job than in that audition
because when I was auditioning this is
Bryan oh okay
cut I don't know you want to do the
second scene do it if you want whatever
so I do the second scene huh cut okay
yeah I really like it to work out how
about what this is good never play poker
with this man that's all I can tell you
I've never offered a man a woman or
anyone a role on the spot before it's
always done through an agent or an off
or something like that but at that time
I got permission and then I walked up to
I remember and there was a camera there
and and and said would you do this and
then there was a awkward conversation
and then because they were and then but
it was complicated but uh and I didn't
have an agent that's maybe why you came
up that's really know and it but it also
there was a discussion too we had on the
steps or after that where I said I said
whether the film sucks or not you'll be
Wolverine for the rest of your life yeah
so prepare for that which I'm very happy
about by the way so yeah
thank God bless here but thank you man
oh thank you that was the moment that
changed my life forever that was one of
those right turns that sent my life in a
way better direction so don't mine too
so love you baby oh I'll leave you in
you I'll leave you to it
uh well hang out for sec oh if you don't
mind yes you
uh I'll uh yeah I'd like to well take
over and bring out some of our friends
of which if I am left to remember
everyone's names I will fail so I'm
going to leave it to you thank you I
appreciate it
here we go let's start off with as
Quicksilver Evan Peters
there it comes
all right as havoc Lucas tale as Jubilee
Lana Condor yeah that's Nightcrawler
Kodi smit-mcphee as Cyclops ty Sheridan
Jean Grey sophie turner beast Nicholas
Hoult Professor X James McAvoy mystique
Jennifer Lawrence as Magneto michael
fassbender as apocalypse Oscar Isaac
as Psylocke olivia munn as angel Ben
Hardy as storm Alexandra Shipp and
writer producer Simon Kinberg holy craps
uh yeah right I see now I see how works
that's good no seats left got a nuts
cool
well I got Michael Fassbender's card I'm
all good now I mean you don't wear yet
all right well you know I can stand
Becky well no I mean you don't have to
stand here but you know you might I
don't know take a look around you know
yeah I'm uncomfortable there's room at
the table I just ruin can I sit on
Jane's lap hi
Wow I was hoping that was mine and we're
done thank you very much I mean that
could be it
well we you serious I don't know hey
yeah let's grab a dry one how about Ron
ladies and gentlemen Hugh Jackson you
you you you come out wait wait you you
use that we want to just okay wait no no
I don't know no no no I just want to
just uh I recognize the fact that you've
been in every single x-men film right
everyone happened yeah up until yeah
yeah old friend always yeah right
remember who the videos emotional your
soul of your life guy got a I have a
good day
I'll see you it's like the longer okay
keeps on giving I got but but you know
my number because we change that my
people your people I can't see your
Jackman again
oh my god how are we gonna get through
all this okay I think we can do it I can
barely see you all the way down there
Simon uh where's that
hello Oscar man uh where's Brian Brian
there you are right in the middle over
here uh so just sort of walk us through
a little bit and when where are we and
how does this story fit in with the
x-men Canon ah let me switch gears for a
second
okay okay um stop talking
um he's always like this on set -
they're always talking I know uh um
x-men apocalypse takes place 10 years
after x-men Days of Future past in a
completely different world 1983 world
has now accepted mutants thanks to the
great heroism of Raven mystique who
prevented this gentleman from causing a
war between mutants and humans mutants
served for the most part accepted and
embraced by society in some places not
in every place and and so it takes place
in that world and that's where we find
our characters and we also find our
characters in all very different places
and I guess they can talk about that
themselves excellent um you know but I
think probably what will work best is if
we can sort of jump into because you did
bring something to show people if I'm
not oh yeah well yeah film school
disclaimer even though it's been a long
time since I was in film school
um this is what uh this is sort of cut
in trailer format but it represents
maybe only about five weeks of shooting
no no finished visual effects or
anything like that it's just a little
but but what it is is a slight taste I
think of the tone and the essence of the
kind of we were we're making so uh take
a look that seemed to go very well well
that went over uh uh congratulations is
this the first time you guys have seen
any of the footage it's the first time
you've seen the trailer yes chef holy
[ __ ] uh
first of all uh mr. McAvoy uh you you
have the dome now so will dome how did
it feel to actually take on that iconic
part of the road did that make you feel
like I am finally Professor X is good
because I can now see Patrick's shoot
don't have [ __ ] on me
it's good it's good it's nice it's what
I thought I'd always do like right at
the beginning of x-men first class but
I'm obviously we had different ideas so
it's nice to finally even though we've
messed with the character and we've put
them through pitman different guises and
giving them slightly different personas
then you've seen him in the cartoons and
in the comic books and then the movies
that we've seen already ever since 1999
and 2000 it's nice to finally adopt that
iconic look and pay homage to everything
that made all these movies possible
whilst also trying to give it something
different each time as well excellent
for for Jennifer Lawrence is misty are
you more mystique or Raven in this in
this film do you think I'm more Raven as
as we said in the movie that you haven't
seen yet um she didn't want to be the
face of a world that she felt like
didn't exist so is it I mean for Michael
Fassbender with which side can you say
we're magneto to soak it in let it
happen uh where where is magneto which
side can you hear me okay down there
yeah I think he's kind of a guy that
plays both sides yeah goes both a little
misguided uh it depends you know it's
like depends on the day of the week
though you know he's always that kind of
ambiguous sort of villain so when we
meet him in this first film it's he's
more of a you know a simple guy he's
just sort of living a normal life and
it's kind of hung up his cape and his
evil ways and and that's that's where we
sort of discover him and then things
happen he gets sort of drawn back in his
help she no session the third Godfather
so it's the best one really
and Garcia yeah um so it's uh yeah it's
it's sort of a little bit of both
winning as always with magneto I think
you know there's not you know his
motives are in some ways justifiable
it's his methods that are kind of
questionable so um we see both sides of
him here ya mean uh cuz I never I don't
I mean II's he does things that seem
villainous but I don't I don't know if
he's necessarily I mean I feel like
there is he's a human character that
just seems to want things and sometimes
it's hard to tell if those are for
himself or just for for you know all of
mutant kinds you know well I think you
know what you're saying is somebody
who's developed by his experiences in
life and you know as we know from you
know a young age he experiences a
concentration camp and sees you know his
loved ones getting taken away from him
so it develops a certain personality and
and this is another level of that and in
this story apocalypse you know he's
trying to sort of lead a normal life he
falls in love as a family and from then
on things happen excellent uh Oscar
Isaac what can you tell us about
Apocalypse what do you want to know well
the whole movie right now if you would
tell me but okay
what are you allowed to say um well yeah
I play Apocalypse he looked pretty cool
right back in my right uh yes yeah you
know I he's you know it's basically this
world that we have it's it's not the
world that should have been gods just
been asleep and God wakes up and
realizes what what's happened and says
it's got to change and part of that is
this this character who in the in the
comic books he's got so many powers so
many strange things I've never really
been specified and so for us it was
important to figure that out but really
the big one I think is the power of
persuasion because he has to go to
incredibly powerful people like psylocke
and storm and and magneto angel and and
convinced them that his way is the right
way to go and much like a cult leader he
sees people
it needs something that are wanting
something and and exploits that to a
certain extent and he gets these
followers and you know instills his plan
excellent so just because our panel is
because it's very expansive can I just
I'll just kind of ask everyone the same
question if that's okay and we'll just
start with you Evan which is who who is
your character to you like when you know
when you would go into work like who do
you see when you're going to work so
who's Quicksilver to you uh me and a wig
me in a gray silver wig who runs pretty
fast
yeah but isn't going did I say I don't
know what I could say in the jeans
darling um I don't know is that too
tough a question for everyone every
rhyme singer yeah it was saying he runs
too fast but never seems to be going
anywhere okay like what I mean
eventually he does but that's kind of we
as Lisa the beginning excellent
Lucas how does how does havoc fit it in
your panels an Eastman for ten years
dude how does he fit into every or what
he's mean to me yeah but what does he
mean to you and how does he fit in do
both you know what man I was uh I've
been practicing
like how many fans of Dragon Balls here
in here right now probably a few nothing
more than a few so I've been practicing
Kamehameha since I've been like eight
years old and I thought that was how I
was gonna be on first class and it was
like hula hoops a little disappointed uh
but I will I will say that have been
given a little freedom and I've
accomplished all the dreams that I've
had as a little kid
that's what havoc means to me oh please
please have you been up on Hall H panel
before you-know-whats no I haven't my
first comic-con six years ago I was up
in the rafters my buddy has a video of
me it was Peter Jackson and James
Cameron and they were on the panel yeah
they go from them up there and I was
summer up there right uh you'd be
crawling around in the lighting which is
deadly
why no fencing wait six years ago was
different I swear I'm not lying no no of
course was there a second story here I'm
looking up there I can't see now but no
there was where God there's like
thousand dead people up in the rafters
that's where I was supposed to be up
there uh Lana what can you tell us about
Jubilee uh this is mud hi I think Julie
to me is the cool girl that like god
I've been yeah I don't think I'll ever
probably be she has a sick sense of
fashion and an amazing jacket that's
like so yellow and out there and bright
that I just she's just cool good that's
that's what she is
that's all you needs me yeah uh Cody
Nightcrawler
yes Nightcrawler um I'd have to say I
relate to him a little bit he's had a
bit of an emotional upbringing dealing
with his mutant aspects as all mutants
Duke but he finds himself and earns
himself and um he has a great stance in
his faith and he's also extremely happy
all the time and I think that's why his
fans late to him
so yeah excellent perfect answer uh ty
what can you tell us about Cyclops
uh yeah Cyclops and I guess he's uh
shoots beams out of his eyes and he's
angry but I think what's cool about this
is that the younger generation of
mutants kind of get to explore these
characters and who they are and how they
became who we know them as in the
previous x-men's yeah alright good that
was a very politically correct answer
there it's like stepping all around them
and further I feel peace for all like
there's a and babies are good hash tag
puppies that Sophia what did you feel
what was the responsibility coming into
this to this film you know as as Jean
what how did you how did you approach it
and you know did you understand the
weight of it coming in um I felt quite a
lot of responsibility I suppose I mean
farm Coeur portrayed Jean so beautifully
that
I was just kind of like gonna live up to
that one no no um but I mean for Jean
it's exciting because I get a whole new
kind of perspective on her in the way
that um when we last saw her she's like
grade five mutant right she's like
powerful um and it's exciting to be able
to figure out how she you know got that
way and how this alienated young girl
becomes one of the most powerful mutants
um the next moon his dream no not
bragging which is pretty sweet she could
cook two burners Nicolas ha now that you
know that you've lived with beasts for a
while where are you with him I can't
concentrate because I'm still psyched
about the Deadpool trailer yeah Hank
McCoy a K beast for me personally I grew
up watching the cartoon so he's the guy
that I loved in the cartoon and now I
get to pretend to be him so it's it's
cool as [ __ ] excellent James uh I just I
don't really see him as Charles Xavier
or Professor X I just see him as Patrick
Stewart and and anything anything that
he did I I try and do a copy you know I
try and make it better but even he had
some moves and stuff B he's like he's
really old and
Oh only joking he's amazing and I oh he
paid for my house and you know if he
hadn't did what he did in the 1999-2000
then I wouldn't be doing this now and a
huge homage to him I see Charles as
empathy you know that's his greatest
superpower for me and he is the ability
to care and understand what other people
are going through and that's only been
increased by all the chaos and trauma
that he's been put through in the last
few films so every time he's connecting
with somebody it's profound and that's
the most important thing he has way
beyond mind control and way beyond the
ability to read other people's thoughts
but yeah he cares
excellent so just jumping over because
we talked to Jan and Michael and Oscar
uh Munn Olivia uh someone's someone's
come a long way since attack of the show
Olivia Munn we used to we used to cover
Comic Con we didn't sleep for days I
know but I can still deep throat a hot
dog
oh well then mistake it that's I don't
even know if we need to ask you about
the movie at that point next so Ben uh
what did you think about your character
I moved on for us okay fine what what
did you what was the question it was you
don't see senior appear like other
parents so [ __ ] crazy
I love you it's I mean how what is what
did it feel like to come into this I
mean like used to cover this kind of
stuff and now you're okay oh I know it's
like it feels like the mothership
calling me home this feels like ever
it's like the coolest thing ever and
every time I I get so excited to put on
the suit and I get so excited to to
train and do my sword training and and
my stunts and do all it just feels just
like it's just honestly it's like the
coolest thing out there what's so funny
oh well wait for you
oh wait for you Ben what can tell us
about angel yeah it's just a really
[ __ ] cool thing it's like it's just
it's just the [ __ ] coolest good Ben
um dude I have wings
prisoners I have some serious badass
wings and that's the best thing about
Angel I feel like to me I feel like
Angel is like every angry or bitter
thought I've ever had I just embodied in
one person so yeah it's great fun to
play excellent Alexandra uh coming in as
an iconic character Hey yes how was this
how was this experience for you it's
been pretty epic you know with storm she
comes into this and she's kind of lost
she doesn't know what she wants she
doesn't know who she is or how powerful
she can really be and you know she meets
someone like apocalypse who kind of
represents what a lot of a lot of people
in Cairo look for which is like a God
you know and she's just finding her way
and hopefully she can find her way to
the x-mansion excellent well they're
they're holding up a lot of signs here
for me because there is another panel
after this but I feel like we should
probably watch the footage one more time
since we're all here and stuff
you